[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brian baumgardner actor director and of
course played kevin in the office and uh
he co-authored a new book welcome to
dunder mifflin the ultimate oral history
of the office which just went on sale
last week brian good to talk to you how
are you buddy
dan how are you it's nice to talk to you
happy thanksgiving you two give me the
number one question
that was never answered on the office is
there one that stands out
well
wow the the question that was never
answered well i'll tell you what i tried
to answer and i came up with about 12
different answers
is
why are we where we are now right like
let's if you go back in time when the
office was on nbc
we were their number one show for most
of the time we were on
but we weren't like
great we weren't like friends you know
we weren't like billboards in times
square and the cover of vogue every week
shocker
um but
now
you know eight years since we filmed
anything we're the most watched show in
television so really what i tried to do
through this book is to answer that
question which is which is what happened
and and really the show that we were
making for people who worked in offices
why are young people watching why do i
get approached by 12 year olds every day
like how did this happen
um i don't know that there is one answer
um but i think that
i think that that the relationship
between the correlation between
an office setting and a school setting
is
is is a is a pretty pretty was it was
bigger than we thought
did jim and pam become an item
in real life
off the set
no
no
no not at all and you know
jenna actually talked to me in the book
about how
she she always hated talking to people
about it because she felt like that it
was like telling people that santa claus
didn't exist
that like they were not they were not in
love in real life that it was a
television show but i tell you a big
discussion we also have is about it was
kind of the first show
in the history of television
that that inverted the story right so
like most uh comedies
focus on the lovers it focuses on the
young lovers and then you have like a
wacky uncle or something that comes in
and does his funny thing and then leaves
and the office was different right like
the wacky uncle was michael scott right
in the middle of everything
and then you had this love story playing
out just like in the corner like
sometimes there would be nothing except
you know someone would touch great you
know
lightly graze someone's hand and you'd
be like oh
and i think what that did was that made
viewers lean into that story and really
want to see more because they weren't
getting it week after week what's in the
book
um
again
i i wasn't interested in
in oh this is what happened and it was
really cool and funny and and this is
what you should think about what
happened
it it's an oral history right so like my
memory is very different than other
people's
memory and so what i tried to do was to
put all of those things together to tell
sort of our best version of what
happened but again specifically to
really try to answer that question why
why did 57.4
billion minutes
get watched on netflix in 2020. like
that is a number i can't even comprehend
and that doesn't count comedy central
and dvds and
wherever else people are illegally
watching it i mean you know so like just
the number of minutes and episodes that
people are consuming is is insane
what was the audition like
for me
it was uh
i was i auditioned for stanley
oh so i was i was brought in for stanley
and i did uh i did kind of a bold
maneuver because i knew the british
version of the show
and i knew that there was a character
called kevin in in this and i knew that
that was the part that i should play
and so i went in and met with
greg daniels and ken kwappas and ben
silva all these producers and i read
the role of stanley as though i were
kevin
and
it was over and i walked out and i was
like well that didn't go very well
that was that was a bad choice by me
uh and i was i was truly i was walking
out and allison jones the casting
director ran after me and said oh hey
hey brian brian brian actually there's
another role uh they they want you to
read for and i wrote i read for kevin
and i may have told you this before but
one of the coolest things i have
uh when steve carell left
uh the casting director handed me a
piece of paper and she was like hey i
was looking for like cool memorabilia
for steve i didn't find that much but i
thought you would appreciate this
and it was just a piece of paper and it
said kevin malone
and it said brian baumgartner
eric stonestreet
from modern family now fame and uh jorge
garcia who went on to lost and
everything else so it was the three of
us
so who knows maybe i could have been cam
in modern family
where did you come up with a voice for
kevin
you know
it was
so i mean this is way too nerdy for your
audience dan but i was i was a theater
actor right so for me it wasn't like
improv or stand-up like for me it was
about creating characters
and so
i
i created this character
and we began shooting and then the
writers just like
they just fell in love with this
let's just call it childlike sensibility
of kevin
and so it became a little more childlike
a little more mischievous
and uh
and so i would say it sort of uh it sort
of evolved over those first two seasons
to where to where we finally got my
justification is that kevin was nervous
of the cameras that were filming us the
like fake documentary crew and as i
became more comfortable more of my
personality came out what was that first
day with steve carell like
he's
he's a genius i mean i like to make fun
of him and
and and i should
but
i truly believe he is the greatest
improviser in in the history of comedy
he he is
explain that
he is
so anybody i mean anyone who's smart or
funny or whatever can make a joke right
a poop joke a whatever kind of joke that
just gets a laugh
but what steve was able to do is in the
blink of an eye
come up with something funny
that was also a hundred percent
consistent with the character of michael
scott that he had created and also
stayed on the story like the plot of
that particular episode so there was
never any like um
i'll show you an example right like this
is i should not say this right it's a
hilarious show i love seth macfarlane
but you think about like um family guy
right
a ton of the family guy jokes are like
that remember that reminds me of the
time when and they cut to something
totally different and it's really funny
in a you know show with real people that
becomes way more difficult to do and he
never did that he never just thought of
a joke that was funny it was always on
character and on story
um truly i think he's a genius
funniest person on set was who
me
of course
i uh
man i mean who was funny outside of the
show so
not steve i would say with all respect
like he
um i know you know
will ferrell quite a bit like
very really understated
um family guys like it's not about that
right it's like the the opposite of of
how robin williams used to be right like
robin williams was on all of it was
hilarious every moment of the day uh not
steve i
um
funniest
craig robinson who played daryl might be
the funniest stand-up
guy i've ever seen i mean he's he is
really funny he's really funny um
and i find sometimes that i've been out
with comedians
and they're not always the funniest
person at the table
right and
you know sometimes they're
moody you know they pick their spots
it's the guy you don't expect to be
sneaky funny and you're like oh wow
that guy is really funny that guy's
really funny i know but depending on how
famous that comedian is that you're out
to dinner with
he'll get the biggest laughs oh yeah
absolutely whether he's like whether
he's the funniest or not yeah like it's
it's a given that if i say the line or
bill murray says the line oh bill is
going to kill him and mine might be
[Laughter]
be about it
i i i get i get jokes that um i
my biggest laughs now come from somebody
saying something
that nobody quite hears and then i just
repeat it louder and get a big laugh
i don't know
what's the uh best cameo
oh gosh
i mean
i i i mean i have proposed to so many
people i guess you have to say that
i i i joked before
i think i have the world record
for most successful proposals of anyone
in the history of the world i should
contact guinness about that not to me
but me asking someone to marry someone
else and them i assume
saying yes it's been in the
in the
dozens
the multiple dozens
yeah it's it's crazy
i
jim carrey was a nice little cameo
kim oh my god i thought you were talking
about
cameo cameo
everyone asked me about cameo i kept
thinking what the hell is kevin talking
about this that's why i was like oh god
dan you're going there um
the best cameo on the show on the
offense the best cameo performance jesus
that was we need to get our notes
together i know
i
i
um
for me it was kathy bates yeah she had a
couple episodes yeah yeah she
and it was really um she and i went to
smu together no not together that's that
is not true she and i both went to smu
and when i was a student this is this is
cute
when uh my mom will appreciate this when
i was a student she came to like speak
she'd won the oscar for misery
and we ended up appearing on stage there
was like an opening of a theater or
something and i was a student
my mom
uh sent her a book
and had her sign a book to me
and so years later when she shows up on
set um
i bring in this book that my mom that
she had sent you know signed to me like
however many years before and that was
really cool
it could have had a like a better ending
to it i mean it wasn't funny
and i'm trying my best here i got i got
i got to tell you this though this this
i got to tell you because i don't know
if you're going to go here i i was just
in scranton
i went back to scranton this last week
to launch the book right i did my like
new york you know today show stuff or
whatever but i was like we gotta go to
scranton
and in the introduction of the book no
one's heard this story yet dan okay in
the introduction of the book i talk
about how the office takes off and this
crazy success that happens
and one of the stories that i tell in
the introduction of the book was
angela and i go back to scranton very
quickly and um i'm told by someone that
there's a wedding happening in the hotel
we're staying at and that the bride is a
big fan of kevin
and they sneak me into the ballroom
and i come in and she's standing there
through a side door she's standing there
and she starts crying this is a true
story starts crying and she comes up to
me and she wraps her arms around me and
she says to me
this is the greatest moment of my life
and i i say
i truly i was like no no no no no you
just got married wait wait you gotta do
the kevin voice to her don't you you
can't you
i was like
ma'am dude this is not
the greatest moment of your life
so
it's it's this is
2007. that happens right i'm not great
at math 14 years later i just go back to
scranton i sign a thousand books in
scranton this one night
and suddenly
there she is
and she has the photo that was taken
that night and she's like and she has a
kid now
she has a kid i tried to make a joke to
the kid about me being her first love
kid did not get it went over very poorly
very poorly
um i thought you were gonna say that
she's divorced and she showed up to say
hello to you
this is the second greatest moment of my
life
uh the book um and it's a great you know
like just flying through it so many
pictures stories there the interviews
welcome to dunder mifflin the ultimate
oral history of the office and it just
went on sale last week
always great to talk to you bry thank
you again and uh happy thanksgiving hey
happy thanksgiving to you dan and the
next time i'm on your show yeah we'll
find out today yeah you're going to
introduce me
as new york times best-selling author
let's go we'll find out today
we'll find out today okay i don't want
to jinx it well i've put other people on
that new york times bestseller list so
if you're not on there
then it's going to be on me not on you
okay
i'll accept it all right thanks dan
thank you brian all right go out and buy
the book let's make him a best-selling
author brian baumgartner
big georgia bulldog fan by the way